don't know they don't help I'm thrilled
it's about time it should have been over
a long time ago I'm bored I think it's
time to end I think it's time to end I
uh was always a big component of
vaccines and have my mask on but I think
it's time that we just move on
[Music]
thank you
I'm personally very happy that they have
taken away the mass mandate because it's
taken away in restaurants grocery stores
there's filters on the plane why do we
need to still wear them so personally
I'm pretty happy and excited about it
yes I'm excited to go away
98 of society we're not wearing them now
so
it's time for the airlines to do away
with it as well
pandemic
it made some sense anymore
and we've got little kids who've had
masks on for two or three years at the
developmental years and up behind and
it's all messed up yeah we landed and
everyone started seeing the
notifications on their phone and they're
all like do we are we allowed to take
our baths off now are we allowed to walk
around the airport no no one really
knows it just doesn't make any sense and
the fact that you know if we're out and
about everywhere else with no masks but
here we are in the airport we're wearing
masks it makes no sense it was already
extended once and it never should have
been so
I'm ready planes are kind of uh you know
space where we all share germs and I
think the mask mandate was something
that people just felt safe about so I'm
kind of against it if I was flying right
now I would still wear the mask even
though I'm triple vaccinated I feel like
it's just a courtesy to others I think
it's time for the uh Airlines to stop
mandating the mass so
so many other areas where it's not used
not utilized I don't believe or feel
that you wearing the mask in an airport
or airplane for a short long period of
time is going to affect anything one way
or another still as yourself you have to
judge that on your own you know don't
let a law say because a lot of people
didn't get vaccinated and they got sick
and a lot of people got vaccinated they
got sick so it's all up to what you want
to do whatever feels safe for you for
sure